il est 13 heures 12 maintenant et nous
en venons au sujet du jour la guinée
voyage à paris après demain du président
sékou touré qui renoue ainsi avec la
france après quasiment un quart de
siècle de brouille avec nous sur ce
plateau deux opposants au régime guinéen
monsieur jammes soumah et madame nadine
bari
mais d'abord monsieur vous regardez le
reportage de paul nahon et jean-louis
saporito il a été réalisé il ya quelques
jours à conakry avec une étonnante
interview du président guinéen
qu'est ce que vous faites les cotons
choir blanc là
second plan à l'automne distinctif c'est
possible
ouais
le preneur à l'eau potable et quand vous
le sortez dans la rue
vous savez les gens comme ça il est
toujours valide
je la termine conakry qu'est ce que ça
vous apporte ce genre de contact avec la
population
la mère des joies ou la loi morale
un président est à la fois près du
peuple est loin du peuple devant le
peuple
on prévoir les étapes
le peuple et la partie saine de la
nation tout n'est pas peuple
nous appelons le peuple la partie saine
fait le débat raté de l'égoïsme de la
volonté d'exploiter et de pression il
appellera vivre dans le bonheur
vous dites ont dîné il n'ya plus
d'exploitations plus de pression j'ai
arrivée assad non non ne sont pas
arrivés à cinq ans et a toujours la
virilité chez certaines de mystifier le
peuple d'exploiter le peuple de tromper
le peuple
mais ça c'est vous qui le titre utilise
le contraire évidemment ils peuvent dire
le contraire mais la réalité est là la
nature de leurs rapports avec les masses
déshéritées
c'était pourquoi nous disons que être
l'expression du peuple et s être
l'expression du vrai du gîte du bon
quand on dit monsieur le président
l'extérieur que sékou touré est un
dictateur
vous pensez que ceux qui voudraient de
dictateurs n'ont rien compris et n'ont
rien compris parce que monsieur sékou
touré n'a jamais ni avant ni à personne
mais ses intérêts mais il entend
demeurer l'acide est l'incarnation de
son peuple et toute décision arrêtée
démocratiquement par le peuple guinéen
et défendu avec fermeté par monsieur
sékou touré sa mission d'être
la guinée avec six millions d'habitants
sort aujourd'hui d'un isolement presque
complet une économie en faillite
dépendante de l'étranger pour son
alimentation mais un sous sol qui
renferme d'immenses richesses en bauxite
fer or uranium la guinée reste pourtant
l'un des pays les plus pauvres d'afrique
depuis 25 ans son leader sékou touré
dénonce le complot permanent contre la
révolution guinéenne des complots réels
ou imaginaires pour justifier à
l'intérieur la chasse aux opposants
les emprisonnements et les exécutions
sous couvert de lutte anti impérialiste
sékou touré gouverne seul à l'africaine
ignorant les rapports accablants
d'organismes internationaux comme la
croix rouge et un ici internationale qui
dénonçait en 1978 l'existence de 2000 à
4000 prisonniers politiques
aujourd'hui le parti démocratique de
guinée parti unique dans le pays exerce
un contrôle absolu mais on note depuis
deux ans une certaine libéralisation du
régime
sékou touré accueillera l'année
prochaine le sommet de l'organisation
africaine et les pays islamiques les
plus riches commencent à donner des
fonds à cette guinée qui compte plus de
80 % de musulmans ici la construction à
conakry de la quatrième plus grande
mosquée du monde
l'arabie saoudite financer le maroc
construit et c'est toujours dans ce
cadre africain islamique que le
président sékou touré compte poursuivre
son action dans le non-alignement mais
avec une ouverture plus grande sur le
monde extérieur même si à l'intérieur
il faut maintenir selon le président
guinéen 8 même la dictature du peuple
pour le peuple
ma résidence stationnaire
complètement calciné
ça c'est le symbole de notre pratique
les leçons
la sagesse dans la fosse
ce jour-là dimanche dernier à conakry un
invité de marque du président sékou
toure je n'oublierai jamais les
bienfaits qui a dispensé son excellence
ahmed sékou touré président de la
république populaire révolutionnaire de
guinée bien fait qui l'a dispensé et
qu'il continue de dispensaires m'enfin
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire que
aujourd'hui à conakry deux grandes
figures du non-alignement sont réunis
c'en était leur seul président c'est que
je serai à nouveau tout beau tout même
pas faire notre propre éloge de juger
depuis disons un ou deux ans vous êtes
sorti de votre isolement vis-à-vis de la
france
et vis-à-vis du monde extérieur est ce
que vous regrettez de vous être isolé
pendant 25 ans que c'était un peu trop
long à vrai dire je n'ai jamais été
isolée
j'ai dit la vérité mais jamais isolé
jamais et vous dites la vérité je le
dirai que la vérité je ne dis pas que
tout ce que j'ai dit soit la vérité mais
je dirai la vérité de mon peuple
mais qu'est ce qui a changé la situation
en guinée où la situation en france à
votre avis à mon avis à un changement en
france
un changement des prix en france depuis
d'abord il faut le reconnaître du temps
de monsieur giscard d'estaing est venu
ici et nous obtenu langage nouveau
indiquant la volonté de la france de
coopérer loyalement avec la guinée mais
je sais que monsieur françois mitterrand
a défini un programme qui maintenant est
axée sur une véritable coopération sur
la base de l'égalité avec le tiers-monde
nous et on dit quoi de la france
mettront concrètement il entend d'abord
définir la disponibilité totale de la
guinée à coopérer sincèrement avec la
france dans tous les domaines où il peut
être possible d'associer les intérêts de
la france et sur la guinée par exemple
je dois vous dire que la guinée des
richesses fabuleuses potentialités très
immense andy des ders la guinée est un
scandale géologique
cela est vrai et nous ne verrons aucun
inconvénient
au contraire de coopérer avec la france
dans tous les domaines où par exemple la
valorisation de nos richesses fort
minières et géologiques pourrait
l'intéresser mais je ne vais pas en
france pour cela je vais en france pour
une mission d'amitié ans et la guinée
n'ont pas toujours été très facile en
partie à cause de problèmes humains ce
que nous appelons en occident nous les
droits de l'homme que la guinée il faut
bien le dire n'a pas toujours respecté
non pas de la guinée monsieur le
président en est il aujourd'hui
nous avons toujours respecté les droits
du peuple et les droits de l'homme
et je crois que la démocratie le système
démocratique guinéen est en avance sur
la plupart des thèmes démocratique en
europe
je parle en connaissance de cause
monsieur le président c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu ici en guinée dans votre pays une
certaine libéralisation depuis deux ans
et les rapports d'amnesty international
que vous connaissez continue d'affirmer
qu'il ya plusieurs milliers de
prisonniers politiques dans les prisons
voyez les jeux super temps dans l'est et
des season là il ya des témoignages
monsieur le président témoignage de kick
des gens torturés des syndicalistes des
ouvriers natixis qu'allez vous contestez
en biologie et qui nous parle en
connaissance de cause et vous pouviez
désigner l leader fer qui viennent et
s'y tenir un meeting de la sorte c'est
le peuple qui répondrait à ces messieurs
par le président de la guinée rien à
cacher on a voulu on en veut à la guinée
pour avoir dit non au général de gaulle
au moment du référendum
la guinée a assumé ses responsabilités
en toute conscience et cette situation
singulière a été exploitée dans le but
d'isoler la guinée ce plan je n'ai de
compte à rendre à personne car mon
peuple et vous savez le peuple quelle
est sa position à l'égard de fond réside
monsieur le président pour donner
peut-être plus de poids à ce que vous
venez de dire permettez-vous à une
organisation internationale comme la
croix-rouge de venir ici chez vous
constatez je peux venir à tout moment
d'abord ne sont pas membres neige et
l'acceptent pour faire là le démenti aux
menteurs qui en france écrit vous parle
pas seulement la foire où tout homme qui
n'est même pas la guinée
mais pourvu qu'il puisse vous dire la
vérité est autorisé à venir en guinée
circuler dans tout le pays
s'il veut visiter les prisons qu'ils les
visites la croix rouge internationale
n'importe quelle organisation de votre
préférence
monsieur le président autre problème
épineux vous attendez bien sûr celui des
français qui ont disparu en guinée
comptez-vous lors de ce voyage officiel
donner des assurances aux familles qui
attendent en france en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elle dise la vérité sur cette affaire
je ne connais aucun français est apparue
la vie en guinée
je connais des ministres des
ambassadeurs guinéens qui se sont vendus
aux puissances étrangères qui avaient la
double nationalité s'ils sont de la
double nationalité c'est leur affaire
pour moi ce ne sont pas des français ce
sont des guinéens ils ont épousé des
citoyennes françaises
ils ont eu ainsi la double nationalité
par rapport à votre législation mais
pour moi ce sont des guigné monsieur le
président si je vous comprends bien sur
cette affaire ces huit français ou
double nationalité mais à double
nationalité ou français pour vos dtu les
8 10 et 8 mai anne d'années ont été
jugés dignes et ils ont été exécutés
alors vous croyez que la logique n'est
pour la france
la logique n'existe pas pour l'afrique
le sentiment patriotique n'existe pas
pour la guinée la notion de patrie
n'existe pas je ne voudrais pas répondre
à ces questions nous voulons faire
l'amitié tenant compte de l'identité et
aussi de la différence l'identité notre
commune volonté a opéré sur la base de
l'égalité dans l'intérêt de la france et
la guinée
la différence je suis guinéen vous êtes
français